joining me now is mike pompeo former
secretary of state and distinguished
fellow
at the hudson institute uh secretary
pompeo thank you for joining us
what we've learned over the past few
days um about fouching the nih
and the state department is truly
disturbing
your reaction well it should come as no
surprise to anyone that there are
folks the state department didn't like
president trump didn't like me didn't
like what we were doing
and we're going to work to thwart our
efforts that's no great surprise
to hear fauci this morning talk about
how the chinese have an interest in us
discovering what happened is just crazy
talk
the chinese have a deep interest in
covering it up and they've done so
pretty darn effectively
in fact it was the state department that
ultimately we had we had big fights
inside the organization but it was us
ultimately who put out documents in
january 15th that demonstrated some of
the
central facts we now know that lead to
the overwhelming amount of evidence that
demonstrates that this probably did come
from this virology lab
it was good work by the state department
team we overcame lots of internal
bureaucracy to get there
and lots of internal debate from nih
folks who are trying to suppress what we
do in the state department as well
the vanity fair piece secretary
uh describes how miles a guy named miles
you the state department's
principal china strategist began
mirroring
the wuhan institute's website and
compiling a dossier of questions about
its research
the article then claims that in april he
gave this dossier to you
and then you demanded access to the labs
there but then the office of the
director of
intel later that month released this
statement
saying the intel community also concurs
with a wide scientific consensus
that covet 19 was not man-made or
genetically modified
mr secretary why was the dna downplaying
what you were trying to uncover at the
time
well the vanity fair piece is right i
was handed an extensive piece of work
that a fellow named miles you did he's a
professor at the naval academy
that was working for me at the state
department he speaks mandarin he was
able to read lots of things others
couldn't get their hands on
and it was pretty clear it was april
when i received that if i remember right
it was in early may
just a few days after that i was on tv
talking about what i could get
declassified at that point
we worked diligently to get the
intelligence community to classify more
director gradcliff was a great partner
in trying to do that but there were
folks all over the community who just
didn't want to talk about this who
wanted to stay focused on other things
they didn't want the world to know that
the chinese communist party was in the
process of covering
what turns out there have been several
million losses of life you know i'll
i'll leave that to others to speculate
but
when you heard dr fatchi this morning
laura those are the exact same words
the exact same excuses exact same
theories that the chinese communist
party
has presented for over a year now we can
all draw our own conclusions i know this
we had a group inside the state
department miles you a handful of others
working diligently to get this
information out
to the american people so the world
could see what the chinese communist
party had done to all of us
but dr fauci is essentially saying
what the ccp is saying about
china that it's highly unlikely
possible that things happen in a lab but
i mean
you really can't tell one from the other
when the way they discuss the situation
at the start of this pandemic
he implies good faith for the chinese
communist party laura
here we are on the 32nd anniversary of
tiananmen square where we saw the
brutality of this regime a regime that
doesn't care about human life
for doctor fatigue and think for a
moment that the chinese communist party
cared that there were
people in wuhan that were dying whether
it was chinese people or americans
whoever else might be there
is just naive beyond all possible
imagination the chinese communist party
doesn't care for a moment
they have no desire for the world to
know what happened they could clear this
all up in a minute if they wanted to
they've chosen not to i think that's
another link in the chain that
demonstrates that when we get to the end
of this
we will have demonstrated that the
chinese knew what had happened
and their virology lab was at the center
of it now one former nsc official matt
pottinger
actually went on face the nation back in
february to lay out the lab leak
evidence and you probably
don't remember it because it never aired
but here it is now
the types of research that were underway
both by the civilian staff of the wuhan
institute of virology
and also military researchers
were studies into exactly the kinds of
viruses that you know ones that are 96
percent similar to the virus that's now
making us
all sick they were doing gain a function
research
using uh humanized uh mice
mr secretary could this information from
pottinger's extremely smart individual
indicate that
we can't necessarily just rule out that
this
you know this just wasn't some you know
a lab leak or
you know could be even a dual use
situation
yeah we don't know uh i saw the
statements that matt made we knew the
same thing inside the state department
we'd seen the same data
you know the your viewers should note
people talk about this as if we don't
know very much we actually know an awful
lot
about what was going on we talked about
gain of function research the fact that
this lab was level four and had security
leaks before
that there were doctors who became ill
and were hospitalized there in the
fall of 2019 we have an awful lot of
evidence pointing to what happened
what was the chinese communist party's
intention we know there was military
activity taking place
this same laboratory we don't know
exactly what they were doing but we know
this
we know that they don't want you to know
and that suggests to me we should
give them no benefit of the doubt and we
should impose enormous costs on the
chinese communist party until they come
clean
about what happened inside their country
just yes a simple yes or no
should any u.s tax dollars
be going to a any group that is in
partnership
with the wuhan virology institute given
what we know
about china their goals and their lack
of transparency should any of this been
happening
absolutely not it's reckless just
next to secretary pompeo thank you and
by the way um
uh you have an op-ed on tiananmen square
and the protest tomorrow in the hill
everyone has to read this
all of these protests have been banned
by china in hong kong as well
and it's a really important piece and
thank you for writing it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else